I think that becoming the leader of
college and not just any college a
college that's had a hundred thirty plus
year history great tradition great
classicism great eclecticism as well has
been a great challenge for me because
I've learned that a leader has both
frames the leader has to have the
traditional frame and is sometimes
afforded the creative frame those times
to be creative though are limited it's
why if you go to creative leadership
comm I have a whole chart of traditional
leader versus creative leader because
they're two different leaders like one
leader leads by authority and position
the other leads by inspiration and
creativity you know one leader says they
have all the answers one leader says I
might have all the answers one leader
says yes or no the other leader says
maybe one leader says I know I'm right
that the leader says I hope I'm right so
those two leaders exist I think in every
one I as a person was born on the
creative front and so I've had to learn
how to be more authoritative as a leader
I'll have to learn how to balance the
two frames and that's been a great
challenge most creative people tend to
not want to lead because leading means I
mean queer people are always against the
man and when they become the man it's
quite awkward you know people who are
authoritative have difficulty leading
creative people because creative people
are kind of divergent they aren't good
soldiers they diverge they wander too
much so that rift is interesting from
the followers side from the leader side
for those who are leading creatives
and feel uncomfortable with that I think
that the challenge is to be open which
is not normal for a formal leader to be
open to risk how does that leader take
that path that leader should really take
off their suit maybe I feel like try to
be with the people risk that because if
they don't take a risk they will not see
a reflexive outcome if you're a creative
person who is unsure of how to lead
authoritative Lee doesn't want to be the
man I would say gender aside they should
woman up they should man up they have to
realize their their position it's not
pleasant but over time you realize it
has to it has to happen it's necessary
can you be two people at one time
of course I can be a father or I can be
a programmer or I can be a painter we
can do all these things so letting
yourself be both I think is important
frame